where do i even begin
well let's start with small steps is
there anything we can help you with
tonight before you get some sleep
i don't even know where my parents and i
are going to sleep tonight
well i heard they're converting a local
school into temporary accommodation
shall we go over and get a room for you
and your parents
oh i didn't know they were doing that
sure that sounds like a good first step
raul good morning how are you carlos
welcome to my home or what's left of it
my leg has almost healed
and your colleagues have been helping me
to clear up the debris
it's almost ready for us to build a new
wrench
wow that's great did you know the mayor
is surviving tomorrow
apparently she will unveil more relief
packages
oh really great i wonder if it will help
to rebuild my ranch any quicker
if you come to the announcement i can
also introduce you to some of the
volunteers that just finished building a
new church
maybe they can help with your rants too
then we can get a cup of that famous
coffee you've been telling me about
you're on but first how about you put
these gloves on
and help me clear this area yes boss
you